What would Martin Luther think of it all?
500 years after the Reformation , Wittenberg
is preparing for the big anniversary.
100,000 guests will attend a special service
here on the weekend
as part of the church's biennial congress.
Construction cranes have been brought in to
build a frame to hold four church bells.
After all, no church service would be complete
without bells.
The crane company is used to working at great
heights, but here it's more about having a
wide and stable base, as the assembly manager
explains.
„When a bell rings, it exerts a thrust around
three times its weight, and that makes the
structure twist.
And then the whole thing can fall over.
I've seen a bell frame collapse like a house
of cards."
The largest bell weighs nearly three tons.
For the crane company it's far from business
as usual.
“The challenge was to decide how to build
the belltower.
The height is decisive in terms of the tipping
forces but so is the width.
We're also right by the Elbe river.
We don't know how the ground might behave
if it rains a lot.
So we've made it very wide and stable."
It was here in Wittenberg, 500 years ago,
that Martin Luther began speaking out against
the church practice of selling indulgences
to gain forgiveness for sin.
He drew up theses for reforming the church.
He's said to have nailed them to this door.
It sparked the birth of Protestantism.
Half a billion euros have been invested in
the city of Wittenberg
ahead of the anniversary celebrations.
Will enough people come and spend money to
make that investment worthwhile?
No one here's willing to say.
Many believe the anniversary can't be measured
in money.
One thing's for sure, an army of helpers is
making it happen.
Today they're packing communion wafers - enough
for every single person who visits the church congress.
They'll be working for the entire year, earning
just 225 euros a month.
Is it worth it?
"It's definitely worth it, I'd do it even
if I got no money at all.
You learn so much and you get to know so many
great people, you make new friends."
The Brückenkopf hotel in Wittenberg is also
gearing up for the anniversary
Right now they're awaiting the arrival of
a group of bishops from Asia.
The place is almost fully booked this year.
The owner, Renate Schult, has invested many
millions in restoring this old fortress.
She's convinced that the investment was worthwhile.
And she believes the anniversary celebrations
won't just benefit her hotel.
„Everyone here in Wittenberg is grateful for the business opportunities that 2017 has given us.
I see this anniversary as a blessing for Wittenberg,
and for the whole of eastern Germany.
And I see it as a blessing for us Protestants
and for Christians generally who live here in the east.
We are the centre of attention right now."
The crane company has to be very careful with
the bells.
They're on loan from a church in Göttingen
and will only be rung once on Sunday out here
on the meadow.
“We've never built a bell frame like this.
And we're unlikely to do it again soon.
It's quite symbolic."
Could the Luther anniversary ring in a whole
new chapter for Wittenberg?
It's certainly what many in this city are
hoping for.